make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking up with the conclusion
of dark knight's death metal right we
are completely done with this event now
and i feel like a little bit of
explanation's needed here right because
there's a few things that go on first
and foremost
is diana prince wonder woman as she
exists in her current form
versus the batman who laughs and i've
seen a little bit of confusion in the
comments section about this and the the
videos that i've made so i'm going to
clear this up real fast
diana is powered by anti-crisis energy
and the batman who laughs is powered by
crisis energy
now the question is how do these things
work so crisis and anti-crisis energy
are in effect allegories is basically
all they are right that uh
crisis energy is the representation of
selfishness right the idea
of focusing on the present of living in
the here and now and not really caring
about anything else
anti-crisis energy is tied to the idea
of recognizing
that memory that history is all one
significant thing
and that the entire history of
superheroes despite all the crisis
events connects them all right so
it's almost one of these things where
crisis energy is the notion that heroes
have kind of lost themselves and so far
is the fact that they're part of this
great big huge grand tapestry right it's
like standing in a room in a house and
not knowing there's any other rooms or
refusing to see them whereas
anti-crisis energy is kind of like we're
in this great big huge house and there's
all kinds of history here and it's
important that we recognize it right now
they represent two different types of
power
and the funny thing about this is that
selfishness is scott snyder puts it
selfishness and really seemingly crisis
energy itself at the outset
seems to be more powerful than
anti-crisis energy now it's not scott
snyder saying
that like you know selfishness is better
it simply means to to say that if you
look at things in the moment that
appears to be the case but the power of
anti-crisis energy comes
and drawing into the past and looking at
the bigger picture itself
and that's exactly what happens when it
comes to diana and and the batman who
laughs
with these guys facing off against each
other that is as much of a
physical battle as it is a metaphysical
battle right in the sense that batman
who laughs does things like he grabs the
titans takes away their powers and
throws them you know and like with the
intention of killing them and then diana
saves them and then he attacks her while
she's distracted that kind of a thing
like you see that kind of situation
going on but it's also metaphysical in
the sense that their fight is happening
on a much grander scale so literally
when he attacks her
and basically punches her and sends her
flying he sends her flying through both
time and space to the point that they
actually travel back to 160 million
years ago it's interesting because he
even goes as far
as to say that with this whole scenario
going on he makes a sort of offhand
remark right and says that maybe if
folks respect the past this time
that big rock simply just won't go boom
right and this is this is kind of a
double meaning and we'll find out what
the second meaning of this is once we
get to the end of the story but in the
moment when he says that he's talking
about this idea
of earth right that if people respected
the past that if people had learned from
the past
that it basically would lead to this
idea that like we wouldn't have the the
world in its current state and here's
the reason why that happens right as
we're kind of going through this right
you got wally west fighting barry allen
you've got
uh you got aquaman being attacked by his
mom you've got swamp thing
from uh from like the dark multiverse
attacking swamp thing from the positive
multiverse right got this great big huge
fight going on um
one of the things that this really kind
of hits that here the reason why this is
important
is because when it comes to the heroes
understanding their past it was the
writing of dc
comics at the time of those crisis
events to ensure the heroes
would not really remember their past
coming out of the events of crisis on
infinite earth there were a few heroes
who did remember right wally west for
example remembered because it was by
virtue of barry allen dying and then
wally west being aged up from kid flash
into adult flash due to the event the
the energy
from crisis undefended earth that he
became who he was right so he remembered
there were a few other people here and
there that kind of remembered but it was
really murky and really kind of crazy
for example like supergirl didn't really
get a proper
origin that reconciled her existence
after the death of the multiverse until
you got to around like zero hour and
infinite crisis right i mean not even
like immediately after crisis unfolded
was that rectified with hawkman he was a
multiversal character
that existed and didn't really get an
updated origin until something like four
or five years
after the first crisis event so it was
it was pretty murky and kind of all over
the place
leading out the the publishing problems
that dc had at the time
the long and short is that when the
original crisis on infinite earth's
event happened that the heroes most of
them
didn't really remember i would say
something like 99.999
right although maybe like a couple
didn't really remember what happened
or that the multiverse existed or any of
that stuff right you go into infinite
crisis and they they're you know the
multiverse comes
back you go into final crisis and the
heroes are basically told the multiverse
came back so it's like okay but their
history their life as they existed
before the events of crisis on invented
earth that was still lost they still
didn't know about that they knew the
multiverse existed at some point in time
but superman didn't remember what his
life was like
back when he was being published in the
stories before the events of crisis on
infinite earth having essentially
limitless power
he didn't really remember any of that
stuff right you go into the events of
flashpoint where barry allen tries to
save his mom's life he basically ends up
realizing things go
south if he does so he just lets her die
and then dc reboots with the new 52 and
the heroes
lost all their knowledge about their
their existence before the events of
flashpoint
yet again right so they lost knowledge
and then what knowledge they did have
they lost again right so it's kind of
nuts
it's one of these things where uh it's
heroes constantly being written in a way
by virtue of dc's publishing standard it
would seem
that they only ever really live in the
moment but what what this really kind of
points out and the whole status and then
really the whole position of diana
is to eliminate that concept by
destroying the batman who laughs she
would destroy
essentially all the memories that were
lost by virtue of the crisis events and
so while the crisis events will have
happened crisis on infinite earth took
place an infinite crisis final crisis
flashpoint while all those events still
took place instead
the hero's lack of knowledge of what
their life was before those events
happened
would be restored right they would
remember everything right and so that's
really where what diana prince stands
for
and so as these guys are kind of
fighting suddenly batman who laughs
stops her right says like stop we need
to stop like we need to stop fighting uh
and
and it's really wonder woman just kind
of appearing in this almost huge void
right and this giant hand comes out of
nowhere now the giant hand of the
multiverse is iconic for dc comic book
fans right it's been depicted
multiple times over the years and it's
basically the hand that created the
multiverse now for for years gone by
we largely just believed it was the hand
of the presence we largely
believed it was just the hand of like
this my omnipotent being that you only
ever
really see in vertigo comics that was
responsible for the creation of the
entire multiverse and indeed
it wasn't really until we got to like
the dc rebirth landscape with the idea
of dr manhattan
and now with perpetua that we're
actually getting a break away from that
ideology though what we're getting here
at least what we got with with doomsday
clock and and the events of uh the
watchmen being rolled in dr manhattan
all that stuff is that maybe the hand
was dr manhattan it was fan speculation
at best but
it was the idea that maybe it was dr
manhattan but dc revealed no it was not
dr manhattan it was the hand of perpetua
right
the creator of the multiverse as we see
it now and so because of that it was one
of these these kind of bonkers
situations where the batman who laughs
is like this was perpetua's hand right
the birth of the multiverse as it exists
so
going all the way back to when the
multiverse was first created in dc
comics which seemingly happened before
dc started publishing right
you know that's it gets a little crazy
at that point but when the multiverse
was first created
uh the perpetual is the one who made
that right we know that by virtue of
everything from scott snyder's justice
league run
all the way up until now the perpetual
was the one who created the multiverse
but what he says
is that her species are called the hands
right and they're basically on their way
here to erase this entire universe
because
basically they dare to want more right
unless the batman who laughs can kill
them first now
a little exposition right a little
explanation here the idea behind
perpetua for those of you guys who are a
little behind here the idea behind
perpetua is that she was she really just
kind of popped up and broke out of the
source wall and we didn't really know
why she was confined there we just
seemingly knew that she was there it
wasn't until later in justice league
that we learned that she was the
original creator of dc's multiverse that
her race called the hands basically
those who stand above her
head tasked her with going into this
huge empty void
and just creating a multiverse but where
she was supposed to create this
multiverse to suit the direction
of the hands as they had given it to her
she instead chose to make it in her own
image right that only the strong deserve
to survive the apex predators different
things like that so she basically defied
her mission she was told to do a she
chose to do b
that's basically how that worked her
punishment was that her children the
monitor the anti-monitor and the world
forger stood against her right they
basically fought her off
and then informed the hands of what she
was doing and the hands locked her away
in the source wall and she was supposed
to be there for all eternity that goes
into the original dark knights medal
event where the source wall was
destroyed and that freed perpetua and
now perpetua came back and that's where
all all this stuff is taking place right
so that's kind of a
rough you know really sort of ad hoc
timeline of what's going on with
everything happening at the moment
but uh that's the hand that you're
seeing here is that a perpetua but the
idea of the the batman who laughs is
kind of like the hands
don't really care right i mean there's
on such a level of power destroying our
universe would be like destroying ants
on the side of a mountain right it's
just it's irrelevant to them that it was
supposed to serve a particular purpose
it didn't uh and now they're going to
come here and they're going to wipe it
all out and she and it's one of these
things where he says if you don't
believe me then look to the future look
to this future where like i kill you
know
all the superheroes that you have uh
that you guys ultimately defeat me but
half your friends are dead
and you allow it to be that way right
you don't just adjust things or change
things or you know modify things on a
whim
you just kind of let things go forward
look to that future and see what awaits
you and the reality is the hands show up
and kill them anyway right the hands
show up so no matter what they do
seemingly
the hands will destroy them right the
hands will wipe everything out and
seemingly the entire multiverse will be
reborn
yet again and so in in the understanding
and the recognition of that
the batman who laughs goes to make his
move and saying i can wipe out all
existence right and you and i can merge
our powers together right we can combine
our forces together and we can destroy
the hands you know it's payment for your
your willingness to help me
that i will turn the multiverse into a
place of absolute insanity and madness
but
i will spare your world i will give you
guys a paradise world to live on
where everything will be perfect you'll
always be young everything will be happy
what you guys imagine to be this perfect
life i will give that to you that will
be your reward for helping me
i'll just take everything else and in
reality it
really does seem like something the
batman who laughs would do right i mean
of what use is a singular universe in
comparison to an infinitely expanding
multiverse right he can just do
everything he wants with it forevermore
it's not like it's an itchy can't
scratch right he's not the galactus of
the dc universe where it's like i have
to
you just it's not really like that right
it's a promise he can make and i promise
he probably would make and that would
essentially be it now there are a few
other things that i do want to draw you
all attention to in terms of this main
fight that's going on here
uh you know one of the things that
happens for example is that the robin
king cuts off the hand of batman right
and literally batman loses his black
lantern ring in the process there is
also this dark multiverse version
of superman whereby in his universe his
spacecraft was lost on the way to earth
and basically consumed or at least
absorbed the energy of all the stars in
the universe right so he's just
wildly powerful and corrupted he's way
beyond superman one million if you guys
are interested in seeing that we can
cover it
i think it's only like a few pages long
i don't think it's very lengthy
it's not like it's like a one shot where
it's like a 20-page origin story or
anything like that
but you know it might it might be like a
three-minute long video that we make but
i'll cover it if you guys are interested
in seeing it the the reality of this is
focusing back on on wonder woman and the
batman who laughs really the meat and
potatoes of the story here that wonder
woman ultimately does not acquiesce she
doesn't give in right she's kind of like
whatever and so what she ends up doing
is attacking him and sending him forward
through time
all the way to the end of the universe
right where the universe and really even
the multiverse will meet its inevitable
end it's basic heat death that one of
the things that
that kind of exists here and i don't
know i can't really speak to whether or
not this is true
in real world physics but in comic book
lore and comic book comic booktum
the idea here is that the multiverse
essentially exploded into existence with
a big bang and much like how a universe
will condense down into a big crunch the
multiverse would do the same thing right
like by virtue of his gravitational pull
all the energy and existence it would
essentially condense back down into an
infinitely small singularity and then
be reborn as a new multiverse yet again
that's how it's normally supposed to
happen
uh nonetheless they're basically here at
this point where everything is going to
end
the issue with this is that any real
opportunity that diana has
to full-on defeat the batman who laughs
through any measure of a lengthy fight
is basically gone because the hands have
arrived here these beings who intend to
wipe out the entirety of the multiverse
they're
here now and things are about to get
really bad
because again they don't really much
care about the heroes or any of that
stuff
and so it's one of these things where
the batman who laughs besieges wonder
woman yet again right one last time and
is like side with me like if you side
with
me we can save everything right but if
you don't if you destroy me right
because as the heroes kind of unify and
as the heroes fight together and so on
then the anti-crisis energy basically
becomes more powerful than the crisis
energy so essentially the tables are
kind of turning here but it's like if
you if you decide
to wipe me out right if at the end of
all things if you push me in
to this death of this multiverse right
where every universe that's ever existed
is kind of condensed down into this
point then all that will be left is you
and then in turn the hands will kill you
they'll wipe out you know they'll go
back there wipe out your universe and
they'll start all over again right
they'll destroy the multiverse and
that'll be the end of it right they'll
just clean slate
everything so it's kind of nuts because
from there again you kind of switch back
to this battle and you get this really
amazing moment right with batman you get
this really really cool moment we're
back where robin king and his forces
have basically killed
all the members of the bat family and so
it's kind of like i mean all the members
of robin's robin king's forces have died
as well and batman's the only one left
alive but it's one of these things where
because he had the black lantern ring
for a while it takes a little takes a
little bit for the effects to kind of
die off and then robin king's just kind
of like you know like i mean because you
don't have your your black lantern ring
anymore you're basically going to die
batman like that's essentially it it's
curtains for you home slice and then
batman's kind of like you know i've met
a lot of different knees from across the
multiverse and the one thing they all
seem to have in common is that
they would never do something as obvious
as to take a black lantern ring their
most powerful weapon the thing that
keeps them alive
and just put it on their finger so that
if somebody came along and did the most
predictable thing that anybody could do
which is
cut the hand off and remove the ring
that they would that i would somehow die
right he's like that's not the case this
is a
symbolic thing he's like the black
lantern ring is built into me and
literally taps his chest and then from
there
activates his ring and then resurrects
the entire army of robin king
and all the members of the bathroom like
the whole bat family become black
lanterns it's pretty amazing right it's
pretty badass even alfred's back right
looking all decrepit and everything
right look so alfred's back right like
he's he's here now and uh and it's cool
right
it's pretty awesome but it's small
little things like that right in terms
of this fight
between this just you know last sun i
think is this version of superman i
think he's called the last sun um and
this
in this fight between him where he's
just decimating right superman it's not
even close right he's just absolutely
crushing this guy
like it's it's it's not even close i
know people are gonna make a point and
be like actually rob
decimation means to kill one tenth of
everything you know what we can use
we can break it down to mathematics if
you want to and then basically
illustrate how it is decimation
uh but you know in this scenario here
lex luthor pops out of nowhere and
basically tells like superman get out of
here i'll destroy this guy and the
question is how in the world are you
going to do that and lex luthor presents
a new suit this powered by a black hole
right it's
just black hole black hole energy is a
singularity and the problem with this is
that the the superman's like if you use
this suit right this last sunny's like
if you use this suit then you'll create
a black hole singularity you'll wipe out
the entirety of them of the universe or
at least this section of the universe
you'll start sucking everything into it
and lex is like
yeah that's the point and he operates he
activates the self-destruct and creates
a black hole event right and sucks in
this superman
this last son superman alongside himself
and basically obliterates everything
while that's going on at the very end of
the multiverse wonder woman's just like
the hell with it right she's like
whatever if we're here at the end of all
things and i'm gonna go out then very at
the very least i'm gonna go out like the
hero i've always been
i'm not gonna go out as some servant of
the batman who lasts governed by fear so
she grabs this guy
and pushes him into the singularity
right basically destroys the batman who
lasts
and she in turn is consumed by it as
well and basically obliterated right
she's literally destroyed and that's the
end of it right at that point
she just kind of wakes up like she or
not really wakes up she just kind of her
consciousness
sort of uh comes into existence right
and she's just sort of looking around
she's sort of this she's
been basically disembodied right she's
like an ethereal form but she's kind of
like what in the world is going on here
and she's met by uh by another
disembodied voice and they basically say
when we created the multiverse our hope
was that life within would follow a path
that it would ascend from simple
selfishness to greater truths basically
you would become better than what you
are and what we've seen in this
multiverse is that that never happened
when this multiverse was created by
perpetua yes she bastardized it she
she bastardized the whole thing but even
when she was destroyed and her work was
wiped away and a new multiverse was
created and you were given the
opportunity to become better
you didn't right you just stayed selfish
you stayed doing crappy
things you only ever focused on yourself
and refused to accept the fact that
there's a world
bigger than you right that there's more
to this world than how you think and
feel there are
billions and and really like billions
people within your own world and there's
countless life within the multiverse
right that it only ever really came down
to you and so because of that this
existence that you guys you know what
you guys call here this this universe
you live in
this multiverse that exists it's a place
of selfishness sadness and horror and we
wanted to wipe it out
the problem is we can't and the reason
why is because when they
when they basically say that we're going
to take a form to appear to you as what
we see as being our
you know the definitive standard on what
a true hero is they take the form of
wonder woman now it doesn't mean that
wonder woman is the end
all be all what every superhero needs to
be it's the idea
of what superheroes are right what
superheroes stand for
that when these these guys when the
hands are talking about the selfish
nature
of life within the multiverse that
they're basically talking about
non-superhero beings right individuals
the average joe you and me right our
inability to look at the world and see
more than ourselves i mean and that's
that's true right even here in the real
world right like you know we know that
like there are there
there's a greater you know there's a
greater picture out there and there's
other people out there who think and
feel right that's the definition of a
narcissist the person who believes that
only their feelings thoughts and beliefs
matter and that everybody else is
basically irrelevant right that's that's
a narcissist and most people are not
narcissists but most people have a
tendency to think about things with
thinking about themselves first and
everybody else second
and so because of that it's one of these
things where superheroes were kind of
this guiding force that it was kind of
like hey like we could drag you into the
future and we could make you guys
recognize that there's a greater world
in themselves and if you don't want to
well then we'll just get rid of you
right like we'll literally create a list
of
standards on what creates a good person
and anybody who is not part of that list
then we kill and we just keep the rest
and the rest of you guys just live in
fear
hoping you do not not become one of
those people on the list right like you
know people who embody those traits on
the list it'd be very dictatorial and
it'd essentially be earth 3 in the dc
universe but instead superheroes exist
to guide people into a better future to
give them an example of the standard to
live by
to fight for things greater than
yourself to not bend yourself to your
most basic needs to not look at the
world from the perspective of what do i
need what helps
me what makes my life better and instead
focusing on
what makes the lives of other people
better right what makes the lives of
this world that we live in better and
there's kind of going forward from there
and that's how the hands
see superheroes they see them as being
people who were capable of doing great
things and despite the fact that they
stumbled and they fell and they screwed
up from time to time
in the end they were doing not very good
things but they were doing them for the
right reasons right not everything they
did was good
i mean there's some shady stuff i mean
wonder woman killed maxwell lord and
infinite crisis like literally broke his
neck yeah i mean they killed people it
happens
you can't make an ammo without breaking
a few eggs you know what i mean so like
they did some
unsavory things here and there but they
all did it for the right reason why they
did it for the for the best reasons they
possibly could
because they were trying to make the
world better facing off against threats
that otherwise would have torn the world
and even the universe apart and so
because of that
what they say is you know you guys have
kind of given us this example
of what superheroes are supposed to be
about how your multiverse was not
irredeemable it was not beyond being
safe
it was just that it takes a little bit
more of a nudge but you were right when
you said that you know when you were
powered by anti-crisis energy you were
right when you said the shortcoming of
superheroes and the people in the world
is they don't really
understand the fact that they're part of
a much bigger tapestry not even your
superhero
friends know that because they've
forgotten so much of their past and so
from there it kind of goes into
we are going to effectively fix things
right but it's going to require
a great sacrifice on your behalf it's
going to require you to ascend beyond
your current form and to become
something greater than what you are
in essence dc's rebooting not really a
hard reboot but dc's basically reworking
the entirety of everything it's a soft
reboot it's their their
their secret wars 2015 right but it is
in effect a reboot it's basically i mean
we can just treat it this way it's more
or less what it is
it's one of these things where you kind
of you end up having like this great big
huge celebration right you know it's
great
celebration this is this big event going
on uh where all the heroes are kind of
celebrating the fact that like they won
the war against the batman who last they
remember it all which is cool but they
won the war against the batman who last
the day was saved they realized they
lost wonder woman in the process but her
sacrifice is the reason why
everybody still survives so they honor
her right it's not like man where's
wonder woman oh that's why she's dead
it's not really like that you know it's
not really people
laughing about wonder woman dying it's
not really that's them that's not really
the case instead they're all just kind
of taking stock and celebrating the good
things in life which is usually what
happens
after a war takes place right and i just
want to point out here i don't know if
you guys see this i just want to point
out here you got
batman playing the guitar you've got uh
you've got what was what's her name the
black canary chick you got her playing
playing uh playing guitar who cares and
then you got superman singing and then
you got wally west in the drums i just
want to say i want to see this band play
i don't really care if black can air is
there or not but i want to see this band
play but i want to see this fan play
some music if i were being honest i
would trade out black canary well i
would trade her out for wonder woman but
she's not here
right she's basically dead if i'm being
honest i would probably say zatanna
could rock it out right she'd be amazing
on a rock guitar i feel like she would
just start playing songs that were sad
you know like like what did she play
like goth
or like lincoln park with their first
album you know like i'm so misunderstood
by the world
you know the world doesn't understand
singing sad songs about her life you
know nobody understands or you know
things like that
but uh but nonetheless you know it's
cool it's just these little celebrations
but in the middle of this
uh barry allen comes to wally west and
says i need you to come with me there's
something i need to show you
and what they what he does is he takes
him to the to this place in the moon and
then says
i need you to vibrate at a frequency of
160.4 gigahertz which one of the one of
the reasons why that's done is because
remember the universe the the various
multiverses out there
essentially exist by virtue of tuning
walls tuning forks right in the sense
that like they have vibrational
frequencies so it's like the main bc
universe might be at the frequency of c
and then like you know the earth 3
universe might be at the frequency of d
and so in order to access that universe
you have to vibrate at the proper
frequency in order to pass through the
dimensional barriers and get to that
place
but the the the important thing here is
that when that's done what you end up
basically discovering
is that this is a whole new set of
events here right there's this kind of
like massive space station
uh that is is they called the next stage
of the the halls of justice in doom but
uh it's essentially a place ran by by
villains but not really because they're
they're doing bad stuff but because
they're some of the smartest people
in the world the whole project at least
the launch is initially being overseen
by superman and batman
but what they basically realized is that
the actions of wonder woman and what
comes out of this
is colossal one of the first things to
happen is the source wall's gone there
is no source wall anymore right there's
no walls
separating the various universes and
multiverses that exist out there in dc
comics it's gone right seemingly it's
completely disappeared
not only that there is no singular
multiverse anymore now
it's it's multiverses growing at a
geometric rate right there's just
infinitely expanding multiverses going
on and on and on and on
in terms of like the old powers that
existed out there dark side there's no
indication that he's there
that basically the the actions of wonder
woman and kind of recreating the
multiverse is essentially that
the entire old standard of comics of dc
comics is effectively gone
that what this does is it allows the
possibilities for superheroes and super
villains from other universes
to merge and cross over at a at a
constant rate however
that they want to right they call it the
infinite frontier but it basically means
that it's a whole new kettle of beans
batman's visited other bet
batman from other universes but it's
kind of nuts it's cool but what this
does is it gives dc the ability
to kind of initiate this colossal
publishing initiative which is awesome
it expands the dc universe in a way
that's never been done before because
what if i what if
over like in a single batman story right
let's say you're reading your batman
number whatever you know written by
who in the however and then it's a
crossover between like batman and like
three different versions of them from
across the universe every story could
feel like a mini event and i know that
seems
that you know on the surface it's kind
of like i don't know if i want to deal
with a bunch of mini events
but that in turn takes the idea of big
crossover events and i would hope puts
them on the back burner right dc doesn't
really do
massive crossover events anyway they've
done a lot more in recent years than
they used to
but it used to be that they never really
did great big huge crossover events
it's only been because they've been
chasing marvel comics that they've
started doing huge crossover events
relatively consistently right i mean you
can sing me a song in a dance about how
you know
dark nights metal is is not a big
crossover event but it basically is just
because it doesn't have tie-ins does not
mean it's not a crossover event right it
basically is
uh but you know imagine that like this
is on a much smaller scale right so
imagine that like there's some joker
from some alternate reality who's gone
awry
you know and like jump to a different
universe and committed all kinds of
panic and stuff on that universe and so
it takes batman from that universe and
batman from the main dc universe to team
up and stop that version of the joker
right it's cool
it creates all different kinds of
possibilities and it's one of the things
that they say
it's kind of becoming its own different
it's own singular omniverse and there's
an infinite amount of possibilities that
can come out of this right there's no
telling what they can publish what they
can create and now the other thing that
they realize
is that there's two centers of the
multiverse now that one of them
seems to be themselves and the other one
is basically what they call the else
world right they don't really know much
about that world they don't really know
a whole lot about what's going on with
it so obviously that's gonna be some
exploration but the big takeaway from
all this the big significance behind all
this
is that the multiverse is growing to the
point where it's becoming an omniverse
so we have multiple multiverses now uh
and that there are no barriers anymore
between the universes that are out there
so there's
all kinds of publishing possibilities
that can be done it can go on and on and
on and on this is fantastic right this
is absolutely
amazing this is fantastic news i think
it's kind of what dc needed because if
i'm being honest with you guys i think
one of the reasons why
dc struggles so much you know especially
if you guys are keeping track of the
news going on with dc comics i think one
of the reasons why they struggle so much
is because their characters are static
they don't change
they pretty much are the same characters
they've been for a long
long long time they don't really evolve
they don't really grow right
now this would be this wouldn't
necessarily be the worst thing if like
the dc cinematic universe was successful
like marvel characters are pretty much
the exact same they don't really change
that much they changed a little bit but
they didn't really change a whole lot
everything goes back to the status quo
the marvel cinematic universe is what
what makes things more interesting for
marvel comics if the mcu didn't exist
marvel comics would be boring as hell
right but it's the compliment of the mcu
and kind of seeing the characters in a
little bit of a different light that
make things different if dc had that in
terms of their movie form it would be
the same way but they don't right
because
nobody knows what's going on they don't
even know what's going on there like i
have this massive plan on how to how to
make their
dc cinematic universe cohesive and work
and and i
i don't even know who to take that to
but nonetheless or if it's even worth
feeling i have no earthly clue but the
whole point here
is that what you have is a is basically
a brave new world right if aldous huxley
was writing
this event it would look like this it's
a brave new world there's all kinds of
possibilities right so with that being
said guys uh we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
before if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you